if it seems like a lot of people you
know are traveling this holiday weekend
other than us of course the tsa's
numbers back that up more than 10
million passengers have passed through
the airport since Thursday including 2.8
million on Friday and that is a new
record joining us now with some summer
travel tips is Brian Kelly the founder
and CEO of the Points Guy good morning
Brian
thanks for having me of course all right
so if you've already traveled you're
already in this you can't you can't take
it back now you've got to come back so
all these Travelers are out there when
they're coming back through the airports
what should they expect how should they
navigate canceled flights and how bad do
you think it's going to be
well you know my biggest tip is make
sure you get TSA pre-check which will
drastically reduce the amount of time
you spend in security lines and also
pack your patience
um you know the air traffic system is
based uh heavily on uh you know delays
are based on weather so so far this uh
Fourth of July week we're seeing good
weather so hopefully we're seeing smooth
sailing a week ago we saw thousands of
delays a day and that has smoothed out
so I always recommend download your
Airlines app also download FlightAware
it'll actually tell you where your
flight is coming from if there are
delays and you really just have to be
proactive these days but we're looking
uh hopefully to a much smoother Fourth
of July holiday week
all right pack your patience that's my
one bag that always seems to get lost
but I will work on it all right if
you're driving especially up and down
the Eastern Corridor which gets really
crowded what are the best times to hit
the road or the worst
you know it really just depends on the
city but we recommend leaving and this
is the same for flights as well as early
in the morning as possible a ton of
people are hitting the roads this year
we're seeing gas prices down 30 percent
from last summer when gas prices were
through the roof so uh but you know I
always like using apps like GasBuddy
because gas prices vary dramatically
state to state it'll actually help you
plan and fill up at the cheapest gas
stations
if you're looking to go far like Europe
this summer we've already talked about
this week how the prices are really
through the roof we we talked yesterday
about some ways to get around it but is
this a good time to use those points is
that an effective way to try to defray
some of those costs
a hundred percent I I've used frequent
flyer miles this summer to go to Europe
uh Virgin Atlantic has a really good
Fair sale going on right now Air France
my biggest tip is the best frequent
flyer programs are not the American
Airlines they are the foreign frequent
flyer programs in fact if you have
American Express points they just
launched a transfer bonus to Iberia so
uh don't just look at the U.S frequent
flyer programs look at foreign ones and
we're seeing 600 airfares this summer in
economy to Spain and I'm a big fan of
Portugal uh and not just are the
airfares cheap but also once you get
there uh restaurants and everything else
are much cheaper compared to other parts
of Europe I mean that sounds pretty good
right now real quickly before we go for
the parents here at the table if you're
trying to get your kids on vacation and
not break the bank you got any good tips
or places to go
well the good thing is uh domestic
airfares are about even compared to last
year uh so I recommend going
domestically our national parks are
amazing like like Adirondack we're
seeing cheaper Hotel fares so looking
domestically driving can save you
dramatically but uh if you are looking
to go International and take the kids
we're seeing great airfares to London uh
as far as as low as 400 on Norse
Airlines so yeah I recommend using
Google flights to find the cheapest
flights
all right this Colorado girl loves the
national park Brian Kelly thank you so
much